Hello,
Dr. Peterson.
Thank you very much.
And my question is regarding Adhd,
which is something I haven't heard you speak a whole lot about,
maybe a little bit.
Um,
now it seems to me that we are at least maybe just me,
do not quite understand ADHD to what could be its full capacity maybe.
And uh,
cause there's many,
many voices saying that it's an overdiagnosed overblown small mental variance
that's prevalent in boys or it's just young boys being young boys.
And then there are some that would fight and advocate for a very different
treatment in the academic world.
Um,
and I was wondering what you,
what your thoughts are on Adhd itself.
Um,
and on,
uh,
the,
whether you think it's overdiagnosed and maybe advice for me as someone who has
been diagnosed with ADHD on how to overcome it without maybe becoming completely
reliant on prescribed medication.
Okay.
So first of all,
it's definitely overdiagnosed.
Second,
it's,
it's very unreliable.
Psychiatric diagnosis.
Many psychiatric diagnosis are unreliable and that's because psychiatric
diagnosis aren't precisely scientific categories.
They're weird hybrids,
right?
First of all,
psychiatrists aren't scientists.
They're engineers.
Engineers are trying to do something rather than to describe the objective world
and psychiatrists are trying to make people healthy,
whatever that means.
It's actually partly ethical.
It's very complicated.
Okay.
We don't know how to distinguish it from temperamental variation.
So for example,
if you're high in openness and high in extroversion and low in
conscientiousness,
yeah,
low in agreeableness,
conscientiousness and and high in neuroticism,
you're likely to manifest symptoms of Adhd.
It's because your exploratory,
you don't like to sit down,
you're full of ideas,
your attention scatters across a wide variety of topics and you're not very
stable,
temperamental variation.
It's also much more common among boys.
Um,
Panksepp showed same guy with rats that if you deprive young routes of rough and
tumble play,
which is what the young boys are deprived of in school,
let's say that,
uh,
they get hyperactive and then their prefrontal cortex is don't develop very well
because they're not having the right kinds of experiences and that you can treat
that quite effectively with psychomotor stimulants like Ritalin.
So that's kind of an interesting bit of scientific information that no one pays
any attention to.
There was also absolutely no evidence whatsoever that longterm use of
psychomotor stimulants produces increases in cognitive gate zero and there's
plenty of evidence that it's harmful.
So
then the second part of that was what about,
yeah,
adjustments for in the academic world say that would be disability adjustments.
It's like that's a such a rat's nest that I don't want to even discuss it.
I mean it it,
I'll discuss it for like 15 seconds.
There is a never ending multiplication of disabilities.
That's what's happening right now.
The disability offices in the universities are swamped.
Like I know some people have it rough like,
believe me,
I know that I was,
I prob,
I seriously know that I've dealt with extraordinarily damaged people in my life.
[inaudible] you're bloody hard pressed to find someone who doesn't have a
serious problem or who doesn't have a serious problem in a close family member.
It's like,
where do you draw the line with regards to disability?
Well,
you can't,
you can't.
They multiply just like LGBT identities multiply.
Just know g really technically just like that.
Just like intersectionality categories of oppression multiply.
It's,
it's,
it's inevitable the way that you deal with it.
As you have objective standards,
you apply them to everyone.
Not because that's fair.
It's not fair.
If you,
if your criteria for fairness is that everyone has the same outcome,
it's not fair at all.
It's not even close to fair.
It's just less tie radical then the alternatives.
Now we don't know that yet because we haven't seen the full range of the tyranny
of the alternatives manifest itself.
Not In our culture,
but it certainly did in other cultures.
I think it's a bad idea now.
I don't want to be absolute about that.
Like
it's tricky,
you know,
because if you have a disability
that
would allow you to do the work in the university and in the workplace with a
modification,
then perhaps the modification could be made.
But I think that was done a lot better when I was in the hands of the professors
and not in the hands of these crazy bureaucratic structures that have risen up
around the disability issue.
Like they're one of the 10 things that are going to kill the universities or
maybe have already killed them,
possibly because they may,
they're walking corpses as far as I can tell zombies,
so,
and that might be wrong,
but is what it looks like to me.